[تصفيق]
مساء الخير
يسعدني وبشرفني يكون معكم
بعنوان ليس للانسان الا ما سعى
والدتي وتتقاعد ابي
[موسيقى]
بدها تحاول طبعا بده يقعد بالبيت حاولت
كتير طلعوا برات البيت يعني يشتغل فكانت
تقول له دائما
وبيا عبدي اصحى لا اسعى معك طلع ابي عبى
لامي هيك نفكر وانا صغير انه والله ابي
عبده لامي لبعدين بس كبرت وعرفت بعدين انه
هي كلها مشتقه من ايه قرانيه وان ليس
للانسان الا ما ساعه وان سعيه سوف يرى
يعني هذا وعد للانسان مو لواحد
مؤمن ولا مسلم ولا هي للانسان بغض النظر
عن دينه ولا عن قوميته ولا عن جونسو اذا
وعد انه سوف يرى السعي المحور الاول
راح احكي انا بقضيه اساسيه لها علاقه
بتجربه شخصيه حابب انا اول شيء اوضح لكل
زملائنا الاعزاء الموجودين انه انا وليس
ادعاء بالتواضع شخص عادي كنت بالمدرسه
مالي متفوقين يلي بقرا الكارير تبعي بفكر
انه هذا موهوب ولا متميز انا شخص عادي حتى
علاماتي كانت بالمدرسه علامات عاديه ما
كان فيها هالتفوق ولا هالتميز وحتى علامتي
بالبكالوريا كانت على الحد لكليه الصيدلي
بس لما دخلت كليه الصيدلي اجتهدت زياده
وصار معدلي بالاخر معدل ماشي حاله كويس
اهلنا في كليه الصيدله وبعد منا وفدت
لالمانيا لحضر درجه الدكتوراه بالرقابه
الدوائيه الحقيقه التجربه الشخصيه بدي
احكي عنها هي لها علاقه بالغربه وبالغربه
انا انسقلت شخصيتي وتطور ادائي نتيجه
وجودي مع مجتمع هو اهلني لهذا الموضوع
القصه وما فيها انه مره تاخرت حوالي عشر
دقايق ولا ربع ساعه عن المخبر
فاستاذي بيستدعيني لمكتبه فمتت رعبي استاذ
الالماني فكرت بالاخير انه هو بده
يصرفني او يطلعني ويقول لي ما بصير تتاخر
تعرفوا الانضباطيه عند الالماني
لما فتت لعنده على المكتب كان ضحكته
لاذانهم مبسوط وحتى الطلب يضيفني قهوه
يعني استغربت انا كل هالحكي وبتعرفوا لسا
بالبدايه لغتي الالمانيه كويسه خفت
الحقيقه كتير خفت ما الي غير كلمتين قال
لي ما تبني ابدا على الغياب على التاخر
قال لي فقط كلمتين بدي اياك تتميز عن
زملائك شلون بدي اتميز عن زملائي الالمان
هن اللي حوالي
وانا الغريب يلي جاي لهذا المخبر وبدي
اتميز عنهم ولسه لغه يا دوب ماشي حالها
بالعكس والله اشتغلت على هذا الموضوع قلت
لحالي شو بدي اساوي انا حتى اتميز عن طلاب
الالماني بتعرفوا هن بقدسوا قصه الدوام
انا شو صرت اعمل صرت اجي ابكر واحد على
الكليه على المخبر واطلع اخر واحد داوم
السبت والاحد بتعرفوا العطله مقدسه عند
الاجانب بس نحن عنا يلا ناخذها في الطريق
اشي لحتى فرصه الغداء اللي هي ساعه نزلها
نص ساعه وروح اركض على المخبر
المحاضرات والسينارات حاول قدر الامكان
اسجلها وارجع على البيت اقراها
وحضر اسئلتي اللي بعده هيك لبعد ست سبع
اشهر حتى بلش يبرز ازمه اسمي اسمي رفقاتي
وكانوا يعني بين من في بعضهم منهم حاول
يعني مثل ما بيقولوا هيك
يعني يحكي على قصه انه انا عم زود عليهم
بالعكس بس في ناس انا اساعدهم حتى
بتجاربهم العمليه الى اخره اخر مره
بالاخير لحتى كل الدنيا دريت بهالمخبر انه
انا شخص متميز بهل الاداء يلي حكيته انا
حتى مره لما رجعت لعند الاستاذ وشافني
وانبسطت كثير بالحكي واجا هو متاخر انت
انا بدي اخفف دمه شو شايف متاخر عم اتبسم
هيك وقلعني من مكتبه يعني انه يعني جاي
تزود علينا كمان فالحقيقه هذا اللي صبر
لشخصيتي وبالتالي تعلمت انا من الالمان
تعلمت شغلات كتير مهمه اول شيء احترام
العمل عندهم العمل مقدس والعمل بعبر عن
كرامه الانسان ما هو سخره في هو هذا الفرق
انا برايي بين العالم الثالث والعالم
متقدم انه العمل عندهم كرامه والعمل
بالعالم الثالث هو سخره الشغله الثانيه
التواضع يعني حتى الاستاذ وحتى زملائنا
عندهم التواضع هو اساس في نجاحها يعمل
ونجاح العمل بالاخير يكمن في جهود الفريق
لو ما كلنا مع بعضنا كنا طلاب دكتوراه ما
انجزت انا بحسي ولا هن انجزوا كلياتنا ايد
متكاتفين حتى وصلنا للي بدنا اياه
[موسيقى]
المحور التانيه بيحكي فيه عنه في طالب انا
عندي اسمه اسامه يمكن في كتير ناس سالوا
من من صفحه على الفيسبوك كتبت عن طالب
اسمه اسامه هذا اسامه طالب فقير فقير معدم
يعني بس ما كنت بعرفه انا اول شي وقت
لعندي على المكتب وكنت عملت
انه هو حتى عامل تنظيفات حتى وهو فايت
لعندي على المكتب كان عم يقلش على رجله
ففكرت معه شلال ولا معه شيء طلع بالاخير
وقت طلع من المكتب من عندي طلع فيها
كعب وكندره ما فيها كعب لما حكيته قال لي
بدي انقل من شئت عملي لفئه عملي فوجئت انا
انه هو هذا طالب عنا بكليه قلت له وليش
بدك تنقل انت من الفئه العملي قال لي لاني
كان يوم السبت لسه دوام بالدوله يعني قال
لي اذا اعطيتني نقلتني للفئه السادسه لهلا
بتذكرها بصير عندي اربعه وخميس وجمعه عطله
بطلع بساعد ابي هو بشتغل بالفرن عنا
بالضيعه
بنصيره بلشت اعرف منه جايب 239 من بيت 240
بالبكالوريا وما دخل كليه الطب لانه طريقه
طويل وانه بده يتخرج بسرعه ويساعد ابوه
كان يدرس بالفرن يعني
ويعاون ابوه بالعجين وبالخبز وبنفس الوقت
كان يساعد اخواته بالدراسه حتى جيتو على
شان قلت له انا انت بتيجي على الشام بدك
تطلع كل اسبوع بتكلفك قال لي لا صاحب
الميكرو اللي بياخذني على الشام
هو بنته بصف السابع انا بدرسها وعلى اساس
انا ما بياخد مني مصاري راحت الدنيا وقامت
انا طلعت من عماده كليه صيدلي وصلت
للجامعه ما عاد عرفت شو عاد صار معه الى
ان صار بالفين طلعت لالمانيا وشفت كنت عم
بحكي مع رفيقي الالماني كان في مؤتمر لقيت
شاب ركض علي شب متل ما بيقولوا اخته
بتعشقه
ركزوا بوزني وعلاني قال لي انتم يستحيل
تتذكرني انا اسمي اسامه هذا الطالب يلي
انا شفته بس شو شكله بتاخد العائله قلت له
شو صار فيك قال لي رحت للنمسا بعد ما
تخرجوا وطلعت من الاوائل بالكليه وعملت
الماجستير والماجستير تبعيت الاول على
رفقاتك كلياتهم على مستوى الجامعات
النمساويه وافوضوني لالمانيا لحاضر لاعمل
البريزنتيشن تبعي قلت له كيف اهلك شو
اخبارهم قال لي بقبض لحد هلا بتذكر 750
يورو ببعت 500 لاهلي
واهلي صاروا كثير مناح مبسوطين بتعرفوا
فرق العمله ما نسترجن نحكي وهون
بس باليورو
وحكى بعد منا انه انا ممكن يصير طالب
دكتوراه واخذ 2000 يورو وابعت لاهلي 1500
يعني تصوروا حتى هلا هالقضيه حاطتها بجهنه
لاهله يعني انا لحد هلا بوقف انا فعلا بكل
تواضع قدامها شخصيه هالشاب يلي هو واثق من
نفسه يعني عم يحكي الكلام وهو مرتاح جدا
وكانه الامور عاديه جدا يعني الحقيقه
عقدني الي بثقته بنفسه وبحكشه الحلو
ومسؤوليته العظيمه قدام اهله اذا هو تحدث
صعب
وبنفس الوقت صبروا اصابع للنجاح وتحمل
المسؤوليه ولا زال عم يتحمل مسؤوليه
المحور الثالث هو بحكي فيه دائما انه
التحضير هو سر نجاحي المشروع التحضير
تذكرت ابو نواس ابو نواس شاعر كلياتنا
بنعرفه قبل ما يصير شاعر
وياريته ما صار شاعر لانه هو شاعر الاباحي
المعروف
بس هو راح لعند
واحد نحوي اسمه خلف الاحمر قال له انا بدي
انظم الشعر وما بعرف قال له روح احفظ الف
بقت شعر وتعال لعندي بعد ما حفظ فعلا
هالالف بيت اجا لعنده سمع له اياهم قال له
فيني انظم الشعر قال له لا بكير بدك تروح
تنساهم قال له شلون بدي انساهم قال لهم ما
بعرف راح سكن بالدير فتره طويله حتى فعلا
نسي بالاخير انه هو حافظ الشعر اجا لعنده
قال له بدي انظم الشعر قال له الان تستطيع
نظم الشعر شو الفكره منها الفكره انه عبر
راسه معجم كلماته معجم اوزان شعريه ومعزم
بحور الشعر الان اذا عنده موهبه بتطلع
الموهبه المهم حضر حاله انا نفس الموديل
في كتير من زمل الان بيعرفوا انه انا بكتب
كاتب قصصي عندي ثلاث مجموعات قصصيه وعندي
روايه بس انا ما استرجيتك مش القلم واكتب
الا بعد ما قرات انا نتاج لادباء السوريين
الادباء العرب مثل نجيب محفوظ والادباء
العالميين مثل جوجل وتشيكوف
لحتى احسنت اكتب بالادب الساخر وطلعت معي
هالمجموعات اذا تحضير ثم التحضير ثم
التحضير هو سبب كل نجاح يصير
اخر محور بدنا نحكي فيه هو ترصد الفرص
واقتناصها انه الفرس الجيده لا تاتي الا
لمن ينتظرها ويستعد لها هذا كلام كثير
اساسي يعني انا بحكي بقصه ماشي شيء اسمه
حظ بهالدنيا الحظ ممكن يكون يصير مره
بهالعمر وهو ماشي الواحد تنزل عليه قصه
مصاري مثلا اكثر من هيك ما في او يسحب
ورقه يانصيب بعد ما اكون سحب الف ورقه
بالاخير يربح له فيها شويه مصاري هذا الحظ
غير هيك الحظ ما بتجي ما يجي الا
العد لهذه الفرات والفرص الجيده مثل ما
قلنا اذا اخذنا مثالين او ثلاثه بهذا
الموضوع في عنا نحن
بيزوس كلياتهم تعرفوا شو عمل وقت طلع
الانترنت
او موضه الانترنت صفن لا يمكن الا هذا
الانترنت ينجح مع الزمان ويتطور ويتوسع
فحضر حاله بمجموعه منتجات انه يبيعها عن
طريق الانترنت وفعلا منها النقطه هاي
انطلقت الامازون
تبع الامازون فلذلك يعني فكر يبلش هلا صار
عنده 90 الف عامل
جماعه الامازون بالمنتجات من الكتب لكل
منتجات الدنيا صار بين ايدين
ايضا ما في احلى منه سانشيز شاف التويتر
وعليه شويه متابعين قال لحاله خلينا نفكر
نحن شو بدنا نساوي كل ربع ساعه صار يحط
تغريده بس من التغريدات الحلوين يلي الناس
تبلش تتابعوا شوي شوي صار عنده اربعين الف
متابع بعد فتره شافته الشركات الكبيره انه
هذا عليه متابعين وعم يغرد تغريدات حلوه
فكروا بلش كل واحد يساله انه حط لنا
الرابط تبعك وتاخد عليه مصاري بعد فتره
صغيره خلال سنه ربح نصف مليون دولار
من شغله تغريدات يعني قصدت انا انه الواحد
بده يكون
يعني مستعد لهالفرس لحتى يحسن يحكي
ويتابع وينجح متل ما حكينا هلا
واوصل لخلاصه الخلاصه انه يمكن نحن ما
بنحسن من
نافس الغرب لا باقتصادنا ولا بالتكنولوجيا
بس عنا عقول بتاخد العقل وكلياتكم بتشوفوا
قصص نجاح موجوده للسوريين بس احنا بنرجع
للاول شي قصه فريق العمل والتواضع اللي
بنحكي كله بدنا نخلطه خلطه كامله هاد لحتى
ننجح نحن نحن ما بننافسهم ابدا بالاقتصاد
ولا بالتكنولوجيا بس بنوازيهم وبنسبوهم
بالفكر وليك اول مبارح قصه بسيطه تبع شام
ما هيك اللي فازت فيها على مستوى الوطن
العربي كلياته صبيه صغيره فنحن عنا فكر
وعنا قدره على انه ننجز كل
هالقضايا بنجاح باهر مثل ما بيقول لذلك
لازم نشتغل على انفسنا كثير ونطور ذاتنا
بالرغم من انه في بيئات كثيره بتعاند هذا
التطور وبتخليني انا دائما اتراجع نصبر
ونطقن العمل وبالتالي بالميه ميه بده يصير
في معنى اللي احنا نجاحات ان شاء الله
لذلك لازم نتذكر حكي والدتي نرجع ونقول
وتقتله لابي اسعى يا عبدي عم فكر انه هو
عبده هو عبيد نسواننا يعني
اسعى يا
وانا اسعى معك شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]